I've been waiting to upgrade because I knew this was coming along.
This is the 6 Plus.
Yeah, it's big, it's the size of my entire hands and I do not have small hands.
I just feel like I would break this.
This is like holding an envelope or something.
It's kind of like a brick.
I'm not afraid of breaking it, I am afraid that it's just gonna get swiped...
...because it's so big, like it's never gonna fit in my pocket.
It fits in my hand but it's definitely a stretch to get my thumb to the other side.
I can't get in the corner.
The one thing about being big that I do like is that...
...I'll be able to see a little bit better.
I think this is cool 'cause I definitely do a lot of e-mails and stuff on my phone.
And if I have to file stories on my phone or write things on my phone,...
...it can be a little tough.
I was kinda thinking the bigger phone might be good for that.
There is no way it can fit this to my pocket or my purse.
I'm probably going to buy the iPhone 6.
I think I'll have to test it out in the store first.
I think I have to like actually use it to see for sure.